all right so real quick before we get
into it wanted to kind of announce two
things one I will be streaming once this
is live and for a few hours later so if
you're watching this as soon as it goes
live make sure to hit up the stream Link
in the description also on top of that I
want to say that I recently had a bond
giveaway on the dust devil video so I'm
going to go ahead and get a winner for
that one but I also want to say that I
will be giving away a bond on this video
so if you guys want to be under make
sure to be subscribed like the video and
comment your RSN down below but with
that being said going to go ahead and
find the winner real quick all right
random number between 1 and 138
12 this actually works out really good
before because 12 I ended up getting in
a pre-recording of this where I wasn't
actually recording and it was this guy
he didn't have an RSN so I picked this
person and so I felt really bad they had
to re-record it but they actually won
again which is crazy so congratulations
to that name don't know how to say it
not going to try but with that being
said let's go ahead and get into the
video all right hello everyone how are
you guys doing hope you guys are having
a wonderful day and today we are here
with a new with a mil episode number 12
so I just ended off the last episode we
have 157 mil in our bank and our total
stats are 1492 also have Quest points of
175 so we are going to go ahead and do
desert treasure I think here in a second
I'm going to go ahead and get 53
thieving for that though real quick then
we're going to do desert treasure
probably do some other stuff but
eventually during this video we are
going to finish off recipe for disaster
I'm calling that now if I don't you guys
can roast me in the comments do whatever
I I deserve it but yeah we're going to
go ahead and do that I don't think
there's anything really I want to merch
right now so I think I'm just going to
go ahead and get my thieving level up
all right just finished off the black
demon test so going to go ahead and get
another one I said I was going to do
desert treasure I lied you're a liar I
need to upload my last video so I'm
going to have to go ahead and AFK this
fire giant task as well uh definitely
nice though get some strength XP I think
we're like 300K off yeah 94 strength and
here we are so I haven't recorded much
the last day or so I've just been
preparing me myself mentally to do these
quests but we're going to get them out
of the way so here's desert treasure
done so this didn't take me actually
that long I didn't get relatively
unlucky anywhere like didn't fall
through any traps here I got one of the
diamonds with like the lockpick Diamond
within 20 lockpicks so I didn't even
have to rebank there's three Quest
points 20K magic XP which I guess is
cool so uh also got 76 magic and going
to start working on that a little bit
more fking it and whatnot but now this
will definitely be really nice as I
believe I get some sort of ice spell I'm
close ice blitz so yeah we'll definitely
work on that I guess burst burst is what
people do okay but yeah with that said
it's now time for rpe for disaster and
here we go this is the end of shadow of
uh shadow of the storm I definitely
forgot that I had more quests to do
before recipe for disaster I do have to
start Legend Quest too but I feel like I
might as well complete it since I've
never really done that and uh it's
something I'm going to have to do in the
end anyway so may do that I don't know
if I'll just start it or end up
finishing it but you guys will see that
here in a second and this is probably
the saddest part of any quest line so
here we
go and rip that's that's
[Music]
rough well this has gotten a little bit
annoying so at this point I just keep
getting quests that I didn't know that I
need before recipe for disaster so this
is another example underground pass will
be completed now so that is quite oh
Jesus Christ five Quest points that's
really nice so we're up to 184 I mean
here soon I'll get 20000 just so I can
like block four things for Slayer but
that's really nice I'm going to go and
start Legends quest I'm not doing it
I've decided that now after this 45
minute long Quest that it's not worth it
to go ahead and do that now and there we
go finish off the goblin part of recipe
for disaster so obviously as you guys
can see a lot of people still left a lot
of many quests to do but should be
pretty quick and we'll rattle these off
real quick so I won't make too much of a
big deal in the future Clips freed
pirate Pete you're welcome homie and
that is another sub Quest completed so
I'm going to go ahead and do sir amvs
now also just a random wood cutting
level which is really nice I guess and
here goes nothing so sir amikar should
be good to go now I kind of did this out
of order but I just want to get the
longer ones out of the way so this Quest
wouldn't seem as long finishing with the
two long ones so there we go got three
more left probably going to go for I'm
not even going to try to say that and
this is me completing the yeah not going
to say it again I don't know his name
but this is me completing his part of
the quest the monkeys the monkey guys
part of the all right and this is me
completing the monkey guys part of the
quest uh one thing I just realized is I
think I need a cat for the evil day part
and I don't have a cat so this is going
to blow I might have to waste some time
or do something but only two more
members left and then we can take on the
boss and get barrows cloves back again
with that post comom uh right here
though made 2.2 mil on some merchesi Wan
and Dragon Hunter crossbow combined uh I
kind of had to wait a while I finished
the lumber guide uh Quest there but this
is what I was waiting on forever bro my
cat like two days in a row I could not
get a [__] cat I would always forget
about it it would run away that that
[__] pissed me off so much and I was not
going to do it with a kitten I refused
to spend three hours sitting there
[__] trying to catch some [__]
spices from some rats I was like I'm
getting a [__] cat but there we go
finished off recipe for disaster really
big just a really big accomplishment for
this account I'm really happy that I did
that it's a shame I couldn't get like an
actual commentary over this because I
was really excited um it's something I
push off on most of my accounts and I
managed to do decently early relatively
to what I usually do on this one um
right there canceled Off cast went and
got squas first time doing it since
finishing lunar diplomacy so that was
really nice and uh yeah then went ahead
and got ourselves some fire Giants not a
bad task though fire Giants task is done
able to get two ancient shards but
nothing much to see outside of that uh
strength level is getting there 12K away
from 94 uh don't know what I really want
to do as far as attack and defense goes
cuz I mean there's no point in keeping
them low I guess other than for Pang
purposes but let's go ahead and get
another Tas so 172 gargoyles that'll be
really nice really uh decent profit I
guess good XP Superior chance but one
thing that we're very close to is the
herb sack uh didn't really have the time
to talk over it in my last segment but I
did skip the veton task I really wanted
to do it but it just takes so much time
I got stuff to do and I was getting PK
the [__] out of so I got kind of pissed
off got to love that straight postc com
clip but uh yeah hell hound St not too
shabby go ahead and do that in the
catacombs per usual another task done
just finished off some hell hounds I
didn't get any hard Clues cuz I have one
of my bank currently but got up to 94
strength 103 combat and right on the
edge of uh 82 Slayer so going to go
ahead get another task dust devils oh
I'm bursting that that's going to be
nice I just got burst too oh all right
so there we go just finished up my first
task bursting so not too bad I did end
up getting 82 Slayer off of it really
good XP and I kind of got the hang of it
so we should be good to go in here in
the future I'm not giving you no [__]
herb bro and uh time to get another
assignment fire Giants AFK good XP I'll
take it here we are so went ahead and
did a couple Ferro sors
merchesi uh I did go ahead and do a
blitz task or a burst task as you guys
saw but Ferro sceptor 3 I don't know how
much money I was making up here it's
kind of hard to tell I bought those a
little while ago but I think I remember
making about 120k off each one so that's
like 1.3 mil and then today I went ahead
and well I guess yesterday and today I
went ahead and bought like 10 for 6
point or I guess nine for 6.9 92 and I
was able to sell them on for 180k profit
each so that's like 1.6 mil takes a lot
of time but I mean if I'm not doing
anything else with my slots may as well
got to love those Ferro sors
merchesi task and I don't know if I'm
starting to like it but here I extended
neck reels and dust devils which I
needed to do for a while oh man just
what up um actually made a decent amount
of money off these Ferro scepter not
because they had good margins but
because their price just shot up while I
had some bought so yesterday I bought as
you can see four here for 6.9 uh another
one for 7 mil and then I sold them all
off as you guys just saw for 7.5 which
means I made actually like 3.1 mil on
that which is really nice uh I have
another one bought here but I'm going to
go ahead and just H to sell it and go
ahead and buy some more at the price
that I just got that at oh pretty usual
sold off more Ferro scepter 7.4 mil each
I bought them overnight for
7288 so made about 140k on each one in
total about nine I think so that's like
1.3 1.4 mil or so not really like a big
thing going on here but something I feel
like I got to mention uh I'm going to go
ahead and get the ancient book now
because I got to do my neck reels task
and I kind of need a book and I hate
buying the mal addiction Ward constantly
and I guess I get prayer bonus from this
too so it's probably the best way to go
about it uh on my dust devil task I put
off getting this God Cape but I'm going
to go ahead go in the wilderness and get
that now since it's just going to make
this so much better all right here we
are going to go ahead and make it pretty
big commitment here but it is something
that I need to do so 24 emblems we're up
in the price we're buying them all I'm
going to go trade this in I need a room
pouch I'm going to have to use it in the
future uh I know that there's a cheaper
way to go about doing it but I figure I
don't I don't know I don't want to get
scammed or anything so we'll do this and
there we go that is 1.2 million points
going to go ahead and trade now go and
buy this Rune pouch real nice to have so
not value buy one there we go Rune pouch
acquired uh just figured that's going to
save me some space on all my runs not
really necessary right now but 82 Slayer
going to have 85 in the future really
useful for sire and uh since I have The
Sire pet on a main I really want to just
I want to I want to do something with it
on on this account 88 hit points also
just finish off one of my dark totems so
I think what I'm going to do with that
and I don't know if I mentioned it in a
video yet is I'm going to eventually
make it to where I'm going to do like a
loot from 99 Slayer guide uh not guide
but loot from 99 Slayer in the catacombs
and just see what I get from sko after
doing all of my totems so I think
that'll be pretty cool as far as as an
idea I might give up before 99 though CU
99 Slayer is a lot of time another
Superior is about to bite the [__]
dust this [__] killed me a second ago
but run Square oh damn it bro that would
have been so nice I forgot since I have
all the pieces to my [__] totem that
I'm not going to get another totem piece
which pretty depressing but yeah that
thing [__] raped me the first time I
still need to figure out how to deal
with these [__] spawns but we'll get
the hang of it I don't know why I forgot
to record but there's a 177 hounds not
bad nothing to see here just a stray
task coming in with the Jad Tas though I
mean it was pretty hype but uh all right
just woke up uh sold off some Ferro
scepter as you guys can see bought 11
for 7 mil 55k sold them all off for
about 350k profit so that made me 3 and2
mil uh just kind of got lucky I think
cuz the price went up during this time
they didn't have that big of margins but
I'll definitely take it and there we go
so that's 60 agility that's a really
good Mark to hit because now I can do
the Sears course and realistically
that's where I need to train my agility
I hate trading it though so 78 fishing
and some quests have got me to this
point along with just a little bit of
training on my own there we go 79
fishing uh not going to work on this too
much more I just want to get that
agility level and I still kind of need
AFK and do some stuff
and there we go Jad Tas done 30 seconds
off my best time didn't get the pet off
the kill but we'll go ahead and gamble
the fire Cape I guess so bargain it yes
I know I won't get it maybe next time
time for another task hoping for
something pretty decent but 154
hellhounds be some easy strength XP
we'll go ahead and do that and there we
go finished off a hellhounds task I
forgot to do the hard clue that I had
before I started this task so not able
to get a hard clue off of this actually
didn't get any totem pieces or anything
so I'd say it's a relatively unlucky
task but going to go ahead go back to my
boy Neeve oh that's great 230 dust
devils oh my God I recently just
extended them too so that's just hella
Mage XP about to come in here so I think
we're going to get no I don't know I
don't know if we'll get 79 but that's a
hell of a lot of Mage XP and I'm really
hyped here we go so I've been undercut
on these Pharaoh scepter but I'm going
to go ahead and see how much money I can
make by charging them uh it was a pretty
long merch took overnight a little bit
of this morning but uh whenever you
don't know what to do with your money or
whenever I don't know what I have to do
with my money I just do this so uh
bought six going to
make 35k from selling them all off
charge and uh also bought another five
back here for 7.15 so I'm going to make
240k off them the price went up
overnight again which is really nice so
uh I average about what 130k on that 240
on that so I'm averaging around 180k on
I think 11 so I'm making around 2 mil or
so once I charge all these and sell them
should be a little while though boom
there we are so sold off all my Ferro
scepter as I said earlier probably made
about 2 mil off of them uh birds nests
right now have a pretty decent margin if
you crush them I'll go ahead and show
that right now I just brought I just
bought 3K for pretty much 6K on the dot
so 18 mil right there which is a ton but
we'll look up Nest uh we'll see what we
can sell a crush Nest on for uh buys
instantly for 6325 but as you saw right
there they actively traded prices a
little higher uh sells instantly for
that so I could crush all these right
now insta sell them and make 600k uh I'm
going to see what the price is if you
want to instab buy them because I'm kind
of interested in not crushing all these
CU I didn't want to get this many but I
feel like you know I'll see I'll see how
fast they sell on for this and that that
would be a cool 600k profit and I
wouldn't have to crush any it'd be
pretty chill and there he goes 99 Mage
good [__] Bro there we are done with my
devil task really good Mage XP oh my God
no I can't I can't do this I have I have
82 range oh I'm GNA have to cancel it
[__] me see that's a type of [__] that I
don't want to see like boss Tas are cool
usually but I'm not doing armadil uh
another task bloodfell 135 going to go
do that in the
catacombs um as far as rewards though
God damn it man I keep canceling [__] so
I can't get this herb sack I really want
it though another Tas done so that is
blood felds off the uh oh crazy
archaeologist I mean why wouldn't I take
35 I mean odium shards and mal addiction
shards are pretty high right now and
just gets me some KD or KC what the [__]
so we'll take it KD cooking not too bad
you know the wines are just so easy they
make it so nice right there I made 100K
on three different Bandos chest plates
just wanted to include that so you guys
knew where I was making a little bit of
money here I'm going to goe I'm going to
have to go ahead and pause the screen
though so basically we had some crazy
ass dragonclaw merges so if you guys
want to look at the first set of them
basically I bought a dragonclaw for
122.9 sold it for
123.5 easy 600k profit went ahead did
the same margin again so ended up making
another 600k putting us up to 1.2 mil
profit in total off the dragon claws but
then I went ahead and did some more and
here's where I kind of made a little bit
more money the next dragonclaw merch I
did I was able to make 700k off of and
the next dragonclaw merch after that I
was able to make another 600k off of now
after that didn't make as much on the
next one I think I made maybe 100K I
don't end up showing it but it was
really good Dragon claws are really good
if you have a lot of money um sometimes
late at night to hit a decent margin so
it's not bad at all didn't didn't really
expect this at 16 KC but I'll take it no
[__]
way 17 KC we get it we get the backto
back odium oh my or not odium but mal
addiction then
odium what the [__] oh my God I just uh
I didn't I didn't expect that at all
that's [__] oh my God that's like the
best luck I've ever had and it's coming
on some [__] [__] shards but I
think their value is actually a little
more than what it currently says oh my
that's 1.8
mil hell yeah and this is the last kill
of the trip so was moving my mic and
definitely took a hit on that one but
lot of room crossbows right here going
to go ahead and teleport out I think I
can teleport with this since it is yeah
that's weird but yeah so there we go
just finished off crazy archaeologist uh
35 kills not too bad as you guys saw
loot was pretty impressive I would say
but another assignment 174 fire Giants
going to go ahead and do that in the
catacomb so hopefully finish off a totem
I think fire Giants done uh nothing of
Interest I guess I got a ancient Shard
but that was it another hell hound task
another AFK task probably should do my
hard clue um so I can actually make this
video somewhat interest debatable
debatable just realized I recorded that
last clip while my soccer match was on
so hopefully you guys enjoyed that
Crystal Palace up 2 one on Chelsea in
case anyone was wondering what game I
was watching but dropped the hard clue
cuz I forgot that it had a quest
requirement and first kill the task and
we got the we got another hard clue so
hopefully we can do this one that yeah
we can do that finished up my hellhounds
task uh I haven't gotten any [__]
totem pieces in a while cave Horrors
though that's not too bad uh going to go
ahead try to get some BL black masks off
of those I actually will do this hard
clue if I can finish it of course should
be the last step of the clue let's go
ahead and talk to this homie [__] me all
right just like that we're [__] done
with it uh done with it hard clue third
H okay okay all right here we go so my
main account down there talking to a fan
what's up dude uh we're going to go
ahead end off this video God damn it had
to log in on conduit and this is what so
we go ahead and look in the bank 69 mil
[__] memes um going to go ahead and
talk over basically what I've done
recently in the grand exchange uh I've
been buying and selling some Ferro
scepter not a whole lot going on there I
probably made by 800k last night doing
it which wasn't too much but then today
it's been really scattered but I did
make a decent amount of money so
overnight as you guys can see I bought
eight for 7.2 mil uh then I sold one for
300K profit and sold another one for
250k profit uh then went ahead and
bought a three charged one which I was
able to buy for 8 mil and I was like
[__] so I went ahead and charged those I
was only able to sell off three for a f
that's like a 600k profit on each one
but remember I did have to lose um I
guess I didn't lose any money I I made 6
K on two of them uh since I had to buy
one and then I sold off another couple
for 7.9 so all in total I'd imagine it's
around 2.5 to 3.5 mil if you include
yesterday night but I'm going to go
ahead and end off this video so we're
going to go ahead look at the bank real
quick I have 69 mil up there as you guys
can see and then just a ton of [__] down
here um I'm going to go ahead and
estimate what these are worth right now
so if I charge these three they're worth
about 7.9 mil right now and 7.9 mil Time
5 would give me [__] uh uh it's pretty
much it's pretty much like 39.5 yeah
39.5 mil right there so we'll add that
on to whatever the total Bank value is
so uh we'll go to show Bank value
conduit hop on in here boy Uh Oh wait
[__] Bank Val
calculate
136 mil holy [__] so if we add on the
39.5 mil onto that we have 166 so 175
mil it looks like and if you guys don't
remember in this episode we did get a
room pouch which cost us a little over 2
mil and there was something else that we
had to buy that cost us a decent amount
of money that's untradeable now but that
is insane so 175 mil we're going to go
ahead and end off the video [__] all
right so that'll be it for the end of
this video this dude said he wanted to
go to the bank to get his void so he
didn't look like a noob he's a fan
though shout out to him hopefully you
guys enjoyed the video If you guys did
make sure to leave a like if you guys
have anything you want to tell me
comment about it down below you guys can
hit the Twitter in the description also
hit a sub button if you really enjoy the
content but nonetheless with that being
said hope you guys have a wonderful day
and peace and time to get started up
with episode 13 let's go what happens
hopefully we don't die this time and got
78 cooking as well